okay so today I'm going to look at
selective breeding selective breeding is
when humans artificially select plants
or animals to breathe them together so
that we can have particular genes in the
population so we're talking a breeding
different plants together so we can keep
the certain gene or particular animals
with particular characteristics that we
want to keep who breed them together in
order to keep those characteristics so
let's think about it simply we could
have two plants in terms of apples so we
could have two types of apple one could
be red apple and let's say it's red and
tasty so it's got two characteristics
there my other type could be my green
apple and okay I'm gonna say it's less
tasty let's just say it it's okay now
ultimately I would like my ideal apple
would actually be the green apple and of
course I would prefer that green apple
to be tasty but that currently doesn't
exist currently don't have and I would
have to choose between one or the other
so what we can do is we can go out okay
these have got the traits that I want
this one has got the tasty
characteristic and this one has got the
green characteristic from what I want if
I breed these two plants together
my hope is at the end of it all I would
get my green tasty apple something be
happy
so let's think about okay well what do
we use this for most thing we use it for
useful or attractive traits especially
when it comes to agriculture so when we
think about farming we might be thinking
about the fact that if I selectively
breed my cattle
I could breed them so that they produce
more meat
I could breed them so that they start
producing more milk from a dairy farm
and produce more milk
I can sell more milk it's even better if
I produced crops so if I produced plants
it would be attractive if my plans were
resistant to disease so particular
diseases that would normally kill my
plants stop them grow in if they've got
resistance to that great and the same
goes for frost resistance or pest
resistance these are all attractive and
useful features that I might want to put
into my plants or in my animals
something a little bit closer to home is
perhaps thinking about wine the drawer
in a pet dog how pet dog we think about
breeding you could also be thinking
about what kind of things we want to
breed in them so we could be thinking
about breeding for a better temperament
or a particular fur color a particular
size
so we can use selective breeding for a
range of reasons
always focus in on what are we gonna get
out of it so let's think about the
actual process about what's involved we
would look at a population and I'm gonna
stick with the idea of cattle for the
mean time so we can look at a population
of animals so let's imagine these are
our cows and our bulls and I mean said
this is kind it's quite passive
temperament this particular animal
produces tasty meat this one produces a
little milk this one produces a lot milk
this one works well in in heat so in hot
climates
now what first do is have a little look
at my existing stock and see what
characters sorry characteristics I want
so this is my first point from the
existing population what I have in front
of me I would select for the
characteristics I want
so in this example I'm gonna go with I
want a lot of milk okay I can sell that
and actually they've tasted me at the
same time that's great I've got two
options there are the characteristics
that I want then we just need to breed
them together
and a little bit like a pool scenario at
the start we would hope that the
offspring would have tasted me and a lot
of milk however that's not always the
case we're not always gonna get it in
that first generation that has been made
so what we would do is we look at the
population of offspring and similar to
what we've done here would look through
them and go okay so which ones are
showing me the characteristics that I
wanted and then I would breed them again
so I select from the offspring and breed
again and I do this for several
generations that means it's not going to
be perfect in that first set of children
offspring it's not necessarily gonna be
in the next lot of offspring or the next
lot but what we're doing is we're making
those genes stronger because we're
always putting together a lot of milk
and the tasty meat that we're always
putting them together and then we put
them together again and again and again
well ultimately should get to the point
where we have our purest form it's after
several generations we can make select
those best offspring